[Music]
on this Tuesday night crisis in the
Middle
East Israel vows military action to
change the reality as Hamas fires back
the iron do is doing its job our Jeff
SLE is in southern Israel plus how Hamas
gunmen hunted down Israeli civilians
America stands with Israel we will make
sure Israel has what it needs to take
care of its citizens defend itself and
respond to this attack a heart-wrenching
last phone call from a Montreal man to
his mother I hear wal to around sh and I
crumbled to the ground and I
said they're in the midst of killing our
side and RCMP launched a criminal
investigation into Ontario Premier Doug
Ford's Green Belt land
deal global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
Israel is used to fighting Wars but not
like this one 4 days after the deadliest
attack in decades where families
including women and children according
to Israel were killed in their homes
Israel is preparing for a possible
ground defensive in Gaza a warning some
of the images in our reporting tonight
are
disturbing Israeli soldiers going house
to house today retrieving the Dead 4
days after Hamas gunman rampaged through
towns near gaza's border shooting
civilians in their homes one Israeli
General says it's not a battlefield it's
a massacre more than 1,000 are dead
according to Israel and bodies are still
being found tonight A volley of rockets
was launched from Gaza to the southern
Israeli city of
ashalon the response Israel has laid
Siege to Gaza home to more than 2
million people raising whole districts
to D and cutting off electricity plus
supplies of food water and
Medicine the health Ministry says at
least 900 people have been killed and
more than 4,500 wounded unlike Israel
the Gaza Strip has no air raid sirens or
bomb
shelters Israel calls it Mighty Revenge
despite a threat from Hamas militants to
execute one Israel captive for each home
in Gaza hit without warning tonight we
have Team coverage from the region and
around the world our Jeff simple is in
Jerusalem crystal ganing is in Beirut
Lebanon Tua isri is in Ottawa with
information on the Canadian casualties
and Jackson prco is in Washington on how
America is reacting we begin with Jeff
and the situation in southern Israel and
Gaza Jeff Donna Israel is back in
control of its territory but the threat
from Hamas remains as we found out
firsthand hospital staff here in the
Israeli city of ashalon had hoped the
worst was
over on Saturday the hospital just 20
kilm from Gaza was overwhelmed with
hundreds of patients many clinging to
life riddled with Hamas bullets and
shrapnel the hospital itself took a
direct hit we are used to uh fighting we
are used to Injured people that are
coming into the hospital but not in this
numbers the hospital head physician was
trapped inside his
home after Hamas gunman took control of
his town they tried to break into my
house they didn't succeed they moved to
other houses very frightening I I I've
never been so frightened in my whole by
Tuesday Morning the Israeli military had
reclaimed control of its territory and
sealed the Border giving Hospital staff
in ashalon a moment to catch their
breath and grab something to eat but
that reprieve was short
lived on Tuesday afternoon the sirens
sounded warning of a possible incoming
strike residents are used to the
occasional rocket fire which is
typically intercepted by Israel's air
defenses but not this
time we took cover and waited the iron
do is doing its
job but clearly I think pans full here
just a ton of explosions happening all
around us then one Moss rocket made it
through when the bombing finally stopped
minutes later residents emerged to find
their neighborhood in Ruins and take a
look at this just a couple of blocks
away from our earlier position you can
see the impact from that Hamas shell
drilling into the street into the
concrete here the impact shattering
glass all around this residential
neighborhood and now the sirens are
going
again we ran down and huddled together
in this apartment basement one of the
many many bomb shelters in a community
that has long lived under threat you see
we are suffering I have a sick mom here
and I have to to take her uh to bring
her here and it's
hard the bombing continued on and off
for nearly an
hour the power of the blasts leaving
Windows shattered and residents
shaken incredibly there were no reports
of serious
injuries in Canada you have good
neighbors but in Israel we can't make
peace with evil says this
resident but as bad as this looks the
pictures now coming out of Gaza are
undeniably
horrific entire neighborhoods lie in
Ruins after a Relentless barrage of
Israeli air strikes at this Hospital
they're scrambling to treat thousands of
injured
civilians this nurse inconsolable after
learning her own husband was among the
Dead the spokesperson for gaza's
Ministry of Health told Global News
they're facing critical shortages of
basic medical supplies and fuel he
begged the International Community to
open a humanitarian Corridor for
life-saving
supplies but this Convoy of Egyptian Aid
trucks were forced back unable to enter
Gaza due to the constant Israeli air
strikes the Israeli military has now
called up thousands of reservists with
reports tonight suggesting it's planning
to launch an allout ground war Donna
Jeff simple in Jerusalem thank you Jeff
Israel is focused not just on Gaza that
small strip of land in the South where
Palestinians are confined but 200
kilometers north of there on Israel's
border with Lebanon where Hezbollah
another militant group backed by Iran is
targeting Israeli positions at least one
Israeli soldier and several Fighters
have been killed in fighting near that
border crystal ganing is in Beirut and
she was at the funerals for two of those
Fighters
Crystal donova Lebanon is not officially
involved a parliamentarian speaking at
the funerals today noted the resistance
here in this country and in Gaza saying
how Ordinary People are standing up
against Israeli forces and how he says
they will be vict
torious they showered their Martyrs with
flower petals and rice hosam ibraim and
Ali forun are the first Hezbollah
fighters to be buried after being killed
in southern Lebanon since Hamas launched
an unprecedented attack on Israel
hasbalah and Hamas share a common
objective of armed resistance against
Israel MERS chanted death to Israel and
death to America
the US is seen as blindly supporting
Israel while ignoring all the
Palestinian lives taken over the
years this Lebanese parliamentarian told
the crowd the resistance movement will
be Victorious and that not even America
can help
Israel this local Muslim leader told
Global News there is some support in the
West for his people but in general
there's a
bias the West is a main partner with the
crimes that happened he says and that
are happening in Palestine and Lebanon
and
everywhere the United Nations interm
force in Lebanon has been assigned as an
international monitor for more than a
decade it noted more missiles and
mortars being exchanged between Israel
and Lebanon volleys that have occurred
for three straight
days people are naturally afraid because
of memories of 2006 yet at several
points along the southern border in
places where you can see Israeli flags
and homes Lebanese people gather waiting
watching and in some cases
hoping this is a suitable place to
encourage our people to defeat our enemy
here a number of people that we spoke
with today all said that security is
their number one priority and they say
because of that they're turning to
Hezbollah both the party and the militia
saying that Hezbollah will be the ones
to keep them secure into the future
Donna crystal ganing in Beirut Lebanon
thanks Crystal at least two Canadians
were killed in the Hamas attack both
22-year-old Ben mrai from British
Colombia and 33-year-old Alex look from
Montreal were shot in southern Israel
two other Canadians are missing its
belied they were abducted by Hamas toia
isri on what we know about them and the
other Canadians who are safe but
desperate to get out of Israel and
Gaza when Ben Mahi was reported missing
his parents got on one of the last
flights from Canada to Israel they did
not know at the time their son was
already dead it's a terribly difficult
time and and I couldn't imagine anything
worse Mahi was one of more than 260
people killed when Hamas gunman opened
fire on a music festival in southern
Israel knowing Ben can only imagine that
you know there was some kind of
self-sacrifice there that he was looking
out for
[Music]
others 33-year-old montrealer Alexander
look was at the same festival and also
died several Canadians are believed to
be held hostage including Vivien silver
and Adie vatel kapon my daughter TI was
apparently taken hostage by Hamas this
Israeli Canadian father is appealing to
the Trudeau government for help for
Canadians with family in Gaza these are
also anxious hours it's very difficult
Dalia alara's father lives in the
densely populated Enclave now under
heavy bombardment by Israeli forces he
actually tried to leave the Gaza Strip
through the Egyptian border and while he
was there it was bombed so they turned
everyone back torontonian and Dennis
reached out to Global Affairs and says
she's only received automated emails
This Is War where is my government to
help me get out of here
now late this evening foreign affairs
minister Melanie Jolie tweeted that
Canada will start airlifting Canadian
citizens out Jolie says the assisted
departure will be from Tel Aviv in the
coming days with the help of aircraft
from the Canadian Armed Forces Donna all
right teria thanks Israel would not be
able to defend itself without military
support from the United States and today
the American president made it clear
that support is unwavering Joe Biden
called the highly coordinated prise
attack by Hamas an act of sheer evil
Jackson prco on the American
response American support for Israel is
unwavering President Joe Biden confirmed
that during his third phone call with
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu we will make sure the Jewish
and Democratic state of Israel can
defend itself today tomorrow as we
always have it's as simple as
that these
atrocities been sickening a US aircraft
carrier strike group is on route to the
region so are more weapons for Israel
anyone thinking of taking advantage of
the
situation I have one word don't more
than a dozen Americans are among those
killed by Hamas 20 or more are missing
possibly taken captive and they are
responsible to bring the US citizens
back home safe and
sound we expect nothing less from the US
Administration
Washington says it's offering Israel
hostage rescue expertise it is people
who can work on intelligence who can
work on overall planning who can work on
coordination with the Israeli government
uh we are not currently sending forces
uh to Israel Western Nations remain
equally cleare eyed in their support is
We Stand jointly on the side with Israel
said Germany's
chancellor the conflict has showcased
Global
divisions in Moscow Russian President
Vladimir Putin called the situation a
clear example of failure of US
policy while turkey's president
lambasted the US for sending an aircraft
carrier warning it would lead to very
serious massacres in Gaza none of that
has deterred full-throated us support
for Israel President Biden is now
calling on Congress to take urgent
action to approve more assistance as
quickly as possible Jackson prco Global
News Washington I'm Ontario Premier Doug
Ford's plan under police scrutiny coming
up RCMP launch a criminal investigation
into the land swap
deal what was a political crisis for
Ontario Premier Doug Ford has turned
into a police matter today the RCMP
launched a criminal investigation into
Ford's plan to open up green belt land
for development Colin Dello is at Queens
Park in Toronto Colin what do we know
about this
investigation
well Donna this is the rcmp's sensitive
investigations unit that is now
officially probing the Ford government's
actions they will not say exactly who is
under investigation or what the specific
allegations are but this unit is
typically tasked with looking into
corruption or allegations of bribery
this entire situation exploded for this
government over the course of the summer
after two independent reports found that
the Ford government had given developers
Insider access and preferential treat
treatment in the removal of lands from
Ontario's protected Green Belt Premier
Doug Ford has always maintained that he
has done nothing wrong personally today
his office released a statement saying
they are taking this seriously they will
work with the investigators and
cooperate with the investigation but
they also say they have zero tolerance
for any wrongdoing within their
government critics of this government
say this investigation points them in a
completely different
direction now we have a premier who's
under criminal investigation and a
government that's spiraling out of
control what's clear now is this is not
going anywhere for the Ford government
they will continue to govern while Under
The Cloud of a police investigation
already the green belt Scandal has cost
two cabinet ministers their jobs the
premier was forced to apologize and next
week they'll table legislation to
reverse the entire green belt deal Donna
all right Colin Dello at Queens Park in
Toronto thank
you still ahead why Gaza has been at the
center of a deadly
conflict the Gaza Strip is unlike
anywhere else about 80% of the
Palestinians who live there rely on
International Aid Israel controls its
airspace its Shoreline and restricts who
and what gets in and out Human Rights
Watch calls Gaza an open a prison Eric
senson on how it became a hot bed of
anger Gaza is a small strip of land just
40 kilm long but it's packed with more
than 2 million people many are refugees
as a people they've never been given
normal political rights for decades Gaza
has endured wretched conditions and the
constant fear that conflict will
inevitably shatter their lives once more
the majority of residents in Gaza are
refugees or descendants of refugees from
1948 when Israel was created the modern
Middle East began to take shape after
the second world war when the new United
Nations decided to partition Palestine
under a British mandate into a Jewish
State and an Arab State Israel was
created Arabs did not accept the
partition and in subsequent fighting
Israel took over more territory and in
The Six Day War of 1967 Israel took
control of still more land including the
West Bank the Golan Heights and from
Egypt the Gaza Strip and Sinai Peninsula
the Camp David P records returned the
Sinai to Egypt but not Gaza in 1987 an
uprising the first intifada erupted in
Gaza Hamas was established as an armed
resistance to Israel and ever since Gaza
has been at the center of persistent
conflict and human
suffering in 2005 Israel withdrew its
troops and Israeli settlers from Gaza
Hamas as both political party and a
military force seized control of Gaza
but Israel has continued to control the
borders and almost everything that comes
and goes Hamas has launched multiple
attacks into Israel over the last 15
years this is a cycle of violence that
has been going on and um and on since
the Palestinian Uprising but clearly the
latest attack into Israel has
demonstrated a new level of capability
by Hamas backed many Believe by Iran the
attack exploits long years of anger
among Palestinians towards
Israel there were air strikes says this
woman in Gaza what did my children do to
deserve this there's nowhere for Gaz and
Palestinians to go during this time um
when Israel is responding with with such
Force Hamas would know that Israel's
larger military would respond with full
force but their aim it seems is to bring
misery to Israelis that will force them
to want change Eric senson Global
News next the heart-wrenching moment a
mother realizes her son has been killed
[Music]
the family of a Canadian man killed in
Israel has a devastating story to tell
Alex look from the Montreal area was on
vacation in Israel when Hamas launched
its surprise attack Dan Spectre spoke
with his grieving
parents on Saturday around 11:30 p.m.
Montreal time Raquel anona received a
video call from her son that would
shatter her family forever he said
Mommy uh we're in the middle of a
terrorist attack Montreal born Alex look
33 years old had been vacationing in
Israel he was one of thousands of young
people attending a music festival about
5 kilometers from the border with
Gaza when Hamas militants Unleashed a
full-scale assault he had mentioned Mom
that's not just Rockets there's Shooters
active Shooters
everywhere like many look and his
friends tried to flee his parents say he
found refuge in a nearby bomb shelter
all the while continuing the video call
with his mother I hear him yell to his
friends the white pickup is coming our
way and there's a lot of
them so then I hear screaming I don't
see anymore I'm just hearing scurrying
scurrying and then I
hear multiple rounds shots shots shots
shots and I crumbl to the ground and I
said they're in the midst of killing our
son they held out hope that maybe he'd
somehow survived but after a sleepless
night they say a friend of their son
called to deliver the news they had
dreaded and he said I'm sorry to tell
you but Alex was
murdered we all just we all just
crumbled we just
crumble the family says according to a
Survivor they spoke to Alex stayed at
the door of the shelter trying to
protect others he confronted the Kamas
Soldier he fought he thought he fought a
good fight he screamed he yelled they
found some solace in The Compassion of
their Community we're getting strength
from our
Alex uh that he is a hero wish he was
less of a hero he'd maybe still be here
what's made them angry is seeing certain
demonstrators here in Canada in support
of the violence and I said how dare they
do they even know what they are
celebrating the family is living minute
by minute as they work to have Alex's
remains return to Canada as a
funloving generous giant hearted bigger
than
life gift that we got for a short
time not nearly
enough Dan Spectre Global News
Montreal and that is global national I'm
Donna Freez and we leave you with
memorials and tributes around the world
for all the civilians killed on both
sides in this conflict thanks for
[Music]
watching